did Kylie Jenner just confirm she
secretly tied the knot with Travis Scott
I don't know but keeping up with Kylie
and Travis is a full-time job guys and
it's our job it is okay so Stormy's
parents continued to spark marriage
rumors but this seems like a big
indicator that they may have taken the
next step
Kylie posted this pic with a caption
extraño on me esposo that translates to
I miss my husband and of course this
caused fans online to freak out yeah one
user wrote wait husband
another wrote y'all she married married
or what do you think I can feel like
they're trolling us big-time again we
know that this is their cute nickname
for each other but wouldn't it be crazy
if this was their way of really just
telling us that they're married just
putting it out there no PR statement I
would like it I think it's cool I would
think that's cool well here are all the
big indicators on why we're thinking
that they may be together here's Kylie
flashing a massive sparkler heading to
Kim's baby shower in 2017 and then back
in November she captured this shot when
your hubby is performing at Madison
Square Garden tonight and last month
Kylie posted a cute couple pic with the
engagement ring emoji oh my gosh okay of
course et caught up with Kylie's big sis
Kim in December we just had to ask the
question that's on everyone's mind did
Kylie and Travis get hitched
she's Instagram pictures with her and
Travis Scott in a ring we're just asking
you are they they call each other
husband away for they married engaged
what is the situation
you know I'm literally need to ask her
that is gonna be my next question on our
group chat we were chatting on the way
over here and I think we just all think
like that's like you know what they call
each other but I have no idea I'm just
like you guys I'll find out I don't know
if I'll share the news with you guys but
I will I'll have to ask myself earlier
this week the live kick creator tease
that she had exciting news cooking up
one fan asked if her big announcement
was that she was giving stormy a sibling
which Kylie quickly shut down tweeting
no hello okay so for now Kylie and
Travis are both busy working on their
makeup and music empires but they do
have babies on the brain tell me why
okay so a source
Petey Kylie and Travis are going to wait
until he's finished his Astra world tour
before trying for another baby
they want to have another child soon so
it's close an age to stormy but they do
not want to do this while he's busy on
the road how cute I know I like this
little family our source ads Khloe and
Kylie would like to be pregnant at the
same time again how cute would that be
the source said quote it was a real
bonding experience for them but more
importantly it's been amazing for their
daughters to be so close in age there
are so many kids grandkids in that
family that's really where the family's
attention is it's all about the next
generation yep and in the meantime the
lovebirds are enjoying life on the road
together with their baby girl and get
this Kylie revealed in her vlog that
little stormy even gets her own hotel
room on tour I know where's Kylie's
so me and Travis have our own room and
then I always get a separate room so
that I can put
so army so I always get a separate room
for my wardrobe my makeup and also store
me so she can play around and have space
hotel rooms um since she always travels
with us well married or not one thing's
for sure these two love each other and
love their baby girl and of course we'll
keep you up to date with all the latest
Kylie and Travis news so be sure to
subscribe to all things et until next
time I'm at Halle underscore Stephen and
I met Courtney underscore tezo know bye
for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]